Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 21st, 2050. What's going on?
How are you? Hey, it's
almost the end of the year.
Did I take time out to say thanks.
Thank you for being, you
know, bringing your vibe.
Um, seriously, I want to thank everybody
who's been watching. F is for family.
All right. Now, Netflix doesn't give
out any ratings, you know, lonely.
They keep them, they keep
them to themselves. You know,
like a fat kid with cookies.
You know, they don't,
they don't tell anybody what's going on.
So I have no idea.
All I can judge by is the,
uh,
the feedback you guys have been
giving me on Twitter, Facebook,
and wherever the hell else you guys are.
Right?
And now you guys seem to be liking it.
So thank you so much for
watching the God damn show.
Please tell your friends about it. I'm
very happy that people are enjoying it.
We worked our asses off on it. So with
that, let's get on with the podcast.
Um, as you know, it's really late today.
You no later than it usually is.
Um, I just have family in town and,
um,
I dunno.
They're like regular people
so they sleep and um,
you know, they sleep and they sleep
and they sleep. And I am, I don't,
I don't get it.
I mean,
I go to bed after I go to bed after
regular people and I wake up before them,
you know, it's probably
because they're like, I dunno,
more just at peace with themselves
so they could just keep sleeping.
But my brain keeps going on how's
the whole fucking night? So I mean,
I can get about six hours and then I got
to get up and start doing something or
I go absolutely fucking insane. So, um,
I wasn't able to record this morning
because everybody was still sleeping and I
do walk around and be on eggshells.
So of course I'm on the phone with
Versie and we yelling about sports and,
uh, my wife came out and
let me know, you know,
you got to stop walking around
screaming at the top of your lungs,
into your phone,
having sports arguments with people.
You do it at all hours of the day.
You have people on,
on speaker and you're screaming about
sports and it's really affecting the
environment in the house. Now, if I was a
mature adult, I'd be like, you know what?
You're absolutely right.
I should be considerate.
I can only imagine if you were walking
around screaming about all the Shit you
watch on Bravo TV,
that unbelievably fucking,
I don't just do void of any sort of
intellect than that fucking cunt of a
channel. I swear to God,
if I knew somebody in,
in the CIA,
I bet it goes Isis and then Bravo TV
and then whoever's the fight or no,
I don't know who would be the next
person that's going to go after.
It's just as far as
like, you know, fucking
up this country. Isis, Bravo TV, Eh,
uh, I don't know. Bravo TV's.
That's a broad brush that gets rid
of a lot of people. But anyways,
so if I was a mature adult, I would
have just been like, you know what?
You're absolutely right. But instead,
what did I say? I said, well, you know,
you fucking sleep all day. You
sleep. They'll like, you know,
all hours of the day and I
get to walk around tippy toe.
And she was just like talking about that.
It's like, yeah, well I am. I'm talking
about that. Why are you talking about it?
Because I know you're right in the
other area that the of the debate.
So I already have a new year's resolution,
no more screaming on my phone
in the house about sports TV.
And there you go.
Once again,
I'll work on myself as a human being and
slowly stopped being the bill that you
know and love and I'll become
that thing they want you to be.
And one day they wake up, they
go, oh, work's done. I'm bored.
I think I'll go blow somebody else.
And you know what? That's, you know,
that's the trajectory of most marriages.
You know,
everything they liked about you,
they start to fucking hate.
Then they fix it and then they deal.
You're somebody different than they
walked down the street just given handies
who wants one,
who gets jobs?
The married woman coming down
street
took my dog for a walk today all the
way around the block and it didn't ship
once. It's just, you know, it
usually shits like two, three times.
So I got all paranoid and I was looking
around the house trying to find dog shit.
I couldn't find it anywhere.
Then I was thinking like did it shit his
braids out the day before. So they just,
it's got nothing left. I don't
know. You know something.
This might be one for veterinarian.
Maybe I should call him my brother and
just talking the fuck in the empty space
of podcasting. That's
right. Podcast. I did that.
A fighter and the kid
Brian Collins podcast.
I did that earlier today.
So look for that.
You probably wonder what Jesus belt,
why are you so fucking lethargic?
Cause because you only get six hours
sleep now because me and a buddy of mine
went to a burger place that
somebody suggested down in watts.
La is in the watts riots.
That's your reason why people,
white people know about watch.
They got a hamburger place down there
called Hawkins and we went down there,
there was three of us. Why does fuck,
why does fuck a new show on Bravo?
Um, and we drove down there and uh, we
were all laughing, just going, all right,
three of the whities people ever
going to go down to watch, you know,
are we going to get mugged his
second we get out of the car?
Are they going to think we're cops? You
know, all the scared white guy thinks.
And then we showed up and was staring
at the fucking menu and this guy just,
hey, is this your first
time here? Or we go, yeah.
Then they go first timers and everything.
Kitchen yelled at, well, I don't know.
Kids came look at after school special.
It was hilarious.
And then as a white person you're like,
Oh really? Isn't that down? I get it. No,
almost in my thoughts are just fear based.
Right?
And then there's always that one dude's
just got to fuck it up for everybody.
Right. It's guy showed up.
Fucking weird, weird vibe.
Had a US air force bag.
He just sort of left it in the middle
of the area where we eating and then
walked away from it.
Sat in the corner,
was sort of staring at us and he was
eating peanuts. He wasn't eating a burger.
And then he walked outside and walked
around to the open window area where we
were at. And then he offered us peanuts.
We were like, no thank you. We would,
we don't want any of your peanuts.
And then we sort of finished up and we
went to leave and he was staring at us
and he wrote down our
license plate number.
Ah, it's awful. It's awful
what go into war does to you.
But I think he was super
fucking paranoid already. Um,
I'm bummed piecing it together.
I certainly wasn't gonna
have a conversation with
the guy was judging by the,
the, the US air force bag
and then, uh, you know,
the paranoid behavior
and he had something on his fucking risks.
Like he get fucked up his
wrist or something like
that. I have no fucking idea.
But all I can tell you is I'm going to
go back there again because it was the
best guy, Dan Berger. I think I might
be the best Burger I've ever had,
but Jesus fucking Christ, it's
the size of a football. Um,
and you know, if you're a goal
oriented person, you know,
you're going to get about three bites
and going, holy fuck, this is delicious.
You're going to get halfway through
and you're going to be like, dude,
do I win a tee shirt if I
finish this thing? And then
finally just like, you know,
I, I can't, I got to finish this
thing. Ah, fries are delicious.
I got the,
uh,
the fat burger with egg
and it was outstanding.
Um, it's called Hawkins. It's right
off of south central I believe.
And uh, it was fucking
delicious. And I was like, thank
God, because I was bringing,
you know,
it was a recommendation from a couple
of people I met when I did yet another
failed pilot. And, uh, you know,
I love meeting people that are actually
from Los Angeles because they love Los
Angeles. And then they know all
the cool places to go. So, um,
most people who are transplants like me
stay basically in the Hollywood valley
area. So I asked these guys, I'm like,
give me something. What do you got?
What do you guys say you want to,
you want to fucking, you know,
you want to try something? Go and go
down to watts. We went down there,
it was absolutely fucking delicious,
but I'll tell you this right now,
I am paying for it. Uh, there's no
way you won't fit. If you're smart,
you'll go down, then you'll split one. Um,
but if you listening to this podcast,
you're probably not smart and you're
going to order one yourself and you're
going to, you're going to
do what I just did. And, uh,
but it's a wonderful experience until
you get right to the end and your body
keeps saying, stop it. Stop it. What are
you doing? Stop it. And you just can't,
you just keep fucking shovel
and in your face and then
you just lean in on something,
you and on something. You're like,
why did I just do that? Uh, I got,
I got to be on the fucking
elliptical for nine years,
and then all of a sudden a fucking air
force veterans off and your peanuts and
you want to stay and say, no,
you want to stand up straight.
Like you're somebody that
can't be fucked with, you know,
and you just can't do it.
And you just lean in there and then maybe
it comes off as confidence and maybe
that's why it leaves you alone.
I have no fucking idea. But, um,
oh my God, my mouth is dry. There was
so much fucking salt and me right now,
you know, Jesus Christ. But you know what?
It was worth it. I was actually site,
they went down there and watch this
great documentary, which of course,
I can't remember the name of it,
but forest, where did the, uh,
the, uh, the narration on it
and it was all about, mmm,
the history of Los Angeles and the
gangs and all of that stuff and police
violence and everything.
And um,
it actually broke down all those different
areas that you always hear about it,
you know? Oh, you able saw straight
outta Compton and actually know where,
where Compton is. You know
what I mean? It's ridiculous.
It's one of the great
groups of all fucking time.
He should know where it is and it's
La is just so fucking weird like that.
They pave over their history. Then I'll
fucking tell you where anything is.
It's all about the highways.
Take the four oh five to the 10
you guys have watched, said SNL,
sketch the cow for onions.
Right. And they'd be like, Devin,
like that sketch was so fucking accurate
as far as like everybody's obsessed
with like, uh, when did you come
from and where do you live in?
It's always, ah, I took the one
oh five to the one 10 to the 60,
you know,
got off at fucking Mulholland.
It's all obsession about how to get it.
Uh,
I know how you got somewhere because
of this fucking Alicia's traffic.
So anyways,
I am a,
I am full of salt right now and I am not
going to eat again until breakfast time.
Morrow. Ah, fuck. Ah, but it was worth it.
It was fucking worth it.
I had like one bite of that and I'm like,
I am bringing Nia here tomorrow.
And then I got halfway through
the Burger and I was like,
I am bringing Nia here in about a month.
And then I finished it and I was just
like, in six months when I'm not full,
what am I full again?
I'm so fucking full right now.
I can't even finish my sentences.
Oh,
it was Gloria said it's really a feeling
that so few people in the world. No,
most people are starving, you know? So
I'm trying to feel privileged right now,
even though it's a big part
of me wants to kill myself.
Oh,
it hurts to laugh.
Jesus Christ now was Thanksgiving between
two bucks. It was fucking my buddy.
One of my buddies had a pastrami
sandwich. He said, I'm three bites in.
I still haven't made it to the bud.
He was smart enough to stop
me and my other friend just,
we just kept going and he had to fucking
drive.
I wanted real client ran,
wanted to recline the seat so fucking bad.
But I was afraid that if I were Clyde,
it was all going to come
up. All right, Bill enough,
you talked about dog shitting
in overeating. Is this
supposed to be exciting?
Well,
it's that time of year.
It's that time of year when you can say
come on and eat a man hole size fucking
burger. It was incredible.
Um, so anyways, what's,
why don't we,
uh,
why don't we talk about some shit
other than dog shitting in a meeting,
an oversized burger.
Um, AH, stupid password.
I can never reopen thing.
Still fucked it up.
Uh, how about the, uh,
how about those New England
patriots sort of limping along?
Um, I don't think we're going to
do any damage this year. I really,
I just don't think it's our fucking year,
man.
We just got too many injuries and uh,
I watched the giants panthers,
as I mentioned, I, when I was promoting
the F is for family. Last week,
I got to do rich eyes and show.
I called in and I was talking about how
I thought the giants panthers game was
going to be the game of the week is far
as either the giants turned the fucking
corner,
like they always seem to in December and
make one of those great playoff runs to
spite their record.
Um,
or the panthers are going to basically
go into feed it and win the super bowl.
That's what the fuck I was saying. Of
course. Who and what do, what do I know?
Just a comedian.
But I watched the game was a great game
and of course everybody was freaking out
about Odell Beckham in.
I was a guy, Norman, um,
I can't believe back of didn't get
fucking injected, you know what I mean?
I swear to God that was
fucking unbelievable. But
however though a lot of me,
I really enjoyed it. I loved them
getting each other's fate. I didn't,
I didn't like him launching him helmet
to helmet, that type of hit. But, uh,
I was talking to another friend of mine,
I said it reminded me of Mel Blunt and
Golden Richards back in the day except
golden. Richard's fought back. Um,
but it's interesting cause Beckham kind
of acted like a big fucking baby cause
he wasn't getting any catches just cause
he got roughed up a little bit. And uh,
I kind of agree with a w I hope
I'm saying his name right. Becca.
Was it not a pack of, I mean a
Norman, right. Ah Fuck there.
Why don't you look up shit before you
fucking start talking about it then you've
got to type with one index finger and
that's not fun for anybody. Right.
Um, yeah. Josh Norman, he said he
kind of cracked the code on him.
You get under his skin a little bit.
So I think,
I think more people are going to try to
fuck with back home cause God knows if
he just tried to cover him.
You can't, you can't do it.
The, once again, the football
gods love the giants.
They love him.
How to fuck do you get away?
This guy ran like fucking 30
and just jumped in the air,
headfirst into another guy's fucking help,
I guess because it was away from
the play. They didn't see it. Um,
three personal files.
I Dunno.
You know what it really comes down to
you as you know much as all you can. Oh,
the fucking Brady rule.
There really is the superstar rule.
If you're a fucking superstar Rican,
throw that guy out of that game. You know,
you couldn't do it.
He's one of the superstars saying they
need to make their money first and then
about 50 other things and then
they try to protect the players.
Cause even now that the fact that
they're trying to protect players,
why are they protect him? Flip protecting
their wallets now that everybody there.
What's that from?
No,
you are looking at a man that doesn't
judge another man by the size of his
go on what movie?
Fucking Wall Street doe.
Charlie's Shay doing that
scene with his fucking fuck
with Martin Sheen. Right. Oh, Bud Fox. Um,
anyways,
but I was texting back and forth
between Versie and Yannis Pappas and uh,
you know, they kept doing this,
you know, this isn't, you know,
what did giants are coming back and this
is New York, this is what New York does.
And I was just writing.
Eli is from Louisiana.
You know that state met part of the
country that all New Yorkers looked down
upon. You know, he's, he
just country walk Louisiana.
That's who the fuck he is.
All right.
He's yet another Non New Yorker
who came to New York and took over.
Because when you look at the
competition, come on man. You know,
I'm just talking about white people here.
Okay?
I'm not talking about other fucking
ethnicities because I don't know what you
guys are bringing to the table.
I don't pretend to know.
Every once in a while
listen to your music.
I tapped my toes and that's
about the extent of it. Well,
maybe I'd come down and eat your food.
That's about it. But other than that,
I'm pretty fucking white.
So all I know is the white people in
New York at generally speaking you it,
it's not reason not real deep.
Most of those cuts down Wall Street and
not from New York. The jerk off finance,
finance majors from all around the country
go down there and start knocking on
the bone. And what does New York do
about it? They don't do a fucking thing.
They went from gangs in New York when
people just walking around with hatchets
and shit to, to now, it's
just, it's a fucking cake walk.
It's like when a Pachino said this is
like one big pole. Wait, no, they'll fuck.
That's what New York is.
And then if you go there and you succeed,
then they say you're a New Yorker.
You know what I mean? Pad It.
New York is such pds.
It's fucking ridiculous nowadays.
At least with white people, I'm
telling, you know what I mean?
All of great rappers obviously,
and basketball stars and that
type of shift come from New York.
But other than that,
white people are generally speaking,
the average white New York. I'm telling
you, it's just, and he's not bringing it.
He's standing outside of a tad stakes.
You know,
when his sweatpants got his little fucking
Sony Walkman on listening to Alicia
keys.
Oh,
do woo.
You know, thinking you're a part of
it. You're not a part of it. You just,
you just one of the ants running around
Frank Sinatra's from Hoboken,
New Jersey.
He's bridge and fucking tunnel and he
came in and took over your fucking city.
All right.
Eli Manning breathes through
his fucking mouth and he looks,
he looks like a five year old in a
football uniform. He died. Just does,
it's got no style of the man
wears dockers for Christ's sake.
And he comes in there and look at them.
He's lining up under center.
Um,
anyways, why am I shitting all over
them? I actually fucking love the giants.
I do have to tell you though, a
Jew Jpp that fucking, you know,
that wrap that he now has on his hand.
It looks like he's holding a
fucking frying pan. I swear to God.
If somebody on the Patriots deflected
one pass with that fucking thing,
it would be illegal and we
would lose draft picks and I'm,
I'm doing that every week from now on.
That's going to be my new fucking thing.
I'll tell you right now.
Did you see when he knocked down that
passed with the fucking bulk of that,
that bandage on his wrist?
I'm telling you that's his
new move rather than second.
That wasting his energy,
sacking the quarterback.
You just hold up that
giant fucking stop sign.
It's an incredible,
you know,
obviously it's fucking tragic and I am
trying to make light of it because I,
I honestly feel,
you know,
it's just a fucking horrible that that
accident had to happen. But you know,
then all of a sudden the team you want
to win throws a ball and he fucking puts
his hand up in, you know, all the sympathy
goes out the one do you like, dude,
what the fuck is that legal?
He's like holding up one of those
giant light bulbs, you know,
that using science experiments.
MMM.
Anyways, I mean it's almost as
big as my head. I'll tell you,
if you could somehow wrap my head
around your fucking hand, you know,
and stuck it up, you, you wouldn't, you
would lead the league in a past defenses.
Is that what they call them?
I Dunno what they call them.
All I know is I really enjoyed that war
between a Norman and a Odell Beckham and
I loved it.
Norman called him a bitch at the end of
the game and I don't think he should be
fine. Obviously Odell should, you know,
you can't jump off you fucking feed
like that doing a sailor's dive into the
side of somebody's fucking ear hole.
What are you thinking?
You know what I mean? But I swear
to God, it reminds me of Mel Blunt,
Golden Richards. Golden
Richards had blonde hair just
like a Dell Becca, you know?
No, you don't know that. Well, you
know something. I do something.
I like to think about it.
MMM.
Oh fuck. I'm so God damn full.
This is so stupid though. Why? Why,
why did I do this by the way?
I always,
I always forget to do the c out of the
podcast. Email, ladies and gentleman,
the podcast email is bill at
the [inaudible] podcast.com
bill@themmpodcast.com.
Um, oh my God, I'm sorry guys, I
got to keep fucking drinking water.
I'm so full of fucking salt right now.
I'm just talking to a buddy of mine.
He thought he had a tapeworm
swear to God they should be. You know
what you know like, you know what?
Sell like fucking hotcakes
right around this time of year
tapeworms that we're almost at the end
of their lives and if he could just
somehow force it down,
you know,
and just during the holiday season you
eat like a fucking animal and it eats 90%
of the nutrition and then it just fucking
keels over and dies like Marlon Brando
when he's out in the garden with his son
or his grandson.
Wouldn't it be great? Then you can just
eat and drink like a fucking maniac.
And this tape warm just takes it all
and then it dies and then you know,
for the next couple of weeks
when you have to go to the potty,
he just don't turn around and look
the most disgusting fucking
podcast I've ever done. I'm sorry.
I started off with dog shit and I mean,
where do I go? He can't make a comeback.
He might as well borrow a
little further into it. Right.
Um,
is there anything worse than when you go
out to take your dog on a fucking hour
and a half hike and you realize you
only have one shitbag left, you know,
then you've got to make that decision.
I'm either going to leave some stuff,
I'm going to leave some behind like
Willem defoe and platoon or I'm going to
have to get, try to get creative
and that shit in the bag.
And then he got dropped the shit out onto
the new shit and then you just fucking
did it as just, it's a, it's
a fucking nightmare. Oh God.
How gross can this become? I just,
is there any women's still listening?
This is disgusting. Are you like this
guy? You think it's guides? Funny.
Shut up Margaret. Shut
up. All right. Anyway,
a woman right now yelling you
husband or boyfriend right now.
You need to stand the fuck
down. Okay? You know what?
You're going to make them do
this fucking holiday season.
Let them man listen to a fucking
podcast for Christ's sake. Look at him.
He's going to die eight
years before you can.
Can you have a heart and
be nice to him on average,
she's going to die eight years before you.
That's the deal.
I should like Dick Van Dyke,
90 years old and he's still dancing.
Still got the light and his iron man.
It fucking guy was sharp as hell.
I think that's the key to it
is dancing. Is it? I Dunno.
Maybe figuratively dance
thing in your heart.
Walking down the street. Just still
hearing the birds Chirp. Sorry.
Oh my God. Oh fuck.
I'm going to take a on.
You know what?
I may walk down to the comedy store
tonight and then I'm going to get all the
way down. They bill. You want to
go on stage? I can't. I can't.
I'm just going to turn around and
walk back. You know what a great idea.
What do I care? Nobody fucking new ideas
right now, do I? I don't think I did.
I think I had that. Then we've got a
couple, two or three. I have no idea. Hey,
how about I reach a little bit
of advertising for you guys? Huh?
You think I read bad one
a fucking regular day?
Forget about when I got a whole giant
Burger in me. Oh my God. It was good.
Holy fucking shit. Was it
delicious? I can't wait to go back.
Yeah. Is it alright to just be
bulimic every once in a while?
That would've been a great time.
Do it. Oh my God. That
was delicious, right?
Fucking puke for a minute. Straight.
All right. Dollar Shave club, everybody.
All right. Hey you guys. You know
what? Evidently I've figured it out.
According to this copy,
I discovered the key to an amazing shave.
It's simple.
That's exactly what dollar shave club.com
does and why I am a proud member.
Like a million of others.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to my front door for a third
of the price of what the greedy goddamn
raise corporations charges both my
wallet and face. Finally, get some relief.
Joining Dollar Shave club.com means you
can afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want.
Fuck the environment which feels
fantastic and for the smoothest shave.
Use Your fresh dollar shave club blade
with their very own Dr Covey Zee Zee
Shea.
It's not your average shave cream,
everyone.
It's highly quo.
It's high quality ingredients
to makes your skin feels soft,
smooth and moisturized. Your blade will
glide effortlessly across your skin.
If you want the most amazing
shave possible, take it from me.
A borderline illiterate fad freckled fuck.
You's of fresh DSC.
That's dollar shave club blade and
doctor cabbies. Easy shave butter.
Two reasons to join Dr. Shade a
dollar shave club.com/bird today.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar
dollar shave club.com/bar all right,
Trump club.
Everybody shopping is awful.
Jesus Christ who has the patience for
crowded stores all the time to try on 10
pairs of pants that don't even fit well
cause you're too dumb to know your own
size evidently. But here's the
problem. You still want to look great.
You want your cake and eat right?
Well with trunk club you can have it.
You never have to set
foot in the mall again,
but you're gonna have a trunk full
of Greg close. Holy Shit Bill.
How does it fucking work?
Relax. I'm going to read it.
Trunk Club takes the hassles man out of
shopping by shipping you a trunk full of
God damn clothes that fits you perfectly
and make it look like 1 million bucks
with all the new fall styles to
despite the fact it's fucking winter.
Fall of 2016 that's how far I had.
These people are at Trunk Club.
You get a bunch of underwear
with leaves on them.
That trunk club.com/burr you simply
answer questions about your style,
your preferences,
and,
and you know what you're
assigned and expert stylist,
an expert stylist,
they put that on a w two what do you do?
I'm an expert stylist at Trunk Club.
They cure rate clothes from the best
premium blend brands and approved and you
approve what you like and just like
that a trunk arrives on your doorstep.
Holy Shit.
What's in it?
Why a bunch of God damn clothes that
fit you and make you look bright.
Try them on.
Keep what you like and easy return what
you don't like in their prepaid trunk
and help. Maybe you got walk. Kid is
sick of you. Throw him in there too.
Then they go, Hey, I think you
put your kid in it. You Go,
I don't know who that is and you're out.
Try them on.
Keep what you like and then stick it all,
whatever you don't like.
You put it back in the prepaid trunk.
This is not a subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep
from your trunk. No hidden charges,
just great clothes.
It's get started today and Trunk Club
will style you for free plus free shipping
both ways. You only pay for clothes,
the clothes you keep to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/burr one last time.
That's trunk club.com/burr for a trunk
filled with clothes you'll love wearing.
All right, one more. One more read.
Oh God. I'm almost out of water.
Hmm.
Oh God. I think that's all I need
for the next fucking 24 hours.
I really have my hands over my
face right now is full. I am,
you know, if you saw me be like,
oh my God, did a loved one die? No,
I ate a giant Burger and I don't have
enough water. I'm sorry. All right.
M iffy m t watches movement watches was
started by two college dropouts with the
idea to make quality watches
that don't break the bank.
Starting at just 95 bucks and sold online.
They cut out the bullshit retail markup.
Supposedly movements sent some watches
over here, but you know what they did?
And I saw him in a pretty God
damn slick looking. All right.
They go great with a pair
of Pete Carroll dockers,
or maybe you got some balls
hugging fucking James. You know,
if you're cool,
if you're a nerd,
they got to watch for you and it won't
break the God damn bank quality materials
and sleek designs. The Perfect Watch,
the perfect everyday watch. It's easy.
Order online today for free shipping.
Free returns at a 24 month guarantee.
Warranty.
Sorry.
Join the movement and say no to big
brand retail markups and say yes to great
style. Why do I feel like there was
more to that and I didn't get it?
They don't have a fucking,
they don't have a website that we
can go to here for God's sakes.
Let me get back to my email's up. There.
Is he come the end of the year taxes.
Hey Bill, did you think you're
going to have a good Christmas?
Let's do your fucking quarterly taxes.
Give me a nice Santa boot to
the fucking goddamn seeds here.
It's the content is the reeds. All
right. Yeah, there it is. All right.
Uh,
yeah,
it's easy to order is just
for the watchers order online
today for free shipping
free returns at a 24 month warranty.
Join the movement and say no to big brand
retail markups by saying yes to grade
style.
Check out [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] and you'll get 50% off your
entire purchase. They're
already not expenses expensive.
You going to get 15% off,
50% off, 95 bucks. That's
about 12, $13, right?
That's Michael Vincent,
Michael Thomas,
watches.com/burr.
Check it out today,
righty everybody at Sherry's berries.
Do you still love gifts to buy
this season? Of course you do.
And you know what I do too.
You want it,
you want to get it right and
you want it to be easy. Uh,
what you need to say where you can check
everyone off your list and find a gift.
Uh, they are online to love
and it's all online. No Mall,
no parking wars,
no lines.
What I'm talking about
is Sherry's berries.
Every gift from them as an instant
hit. Get Sherry's berries, sweet,
freshly dipped strawberries
starting at just 1999.
That's a 40% saving.
And for today only you can double the
berries for just $5 more or twice as much
for only $5 more. And you, uh,
but you have to use my code bur bur sorry.
These gourmet berries that are frozen
and shipped through the mail are fresh.
You see a dip than dack white and
milk chocolate and deliciousness.
Then there's sprinkled with decorative
toppings like chocolate chips and chop
nuts. It's pretty pedestrian
to be called decadent.
This special sale is for only today.
Make sure you order today to double
your berries for only five bucks. Dude,
everybody and know who ordered these,
said they're fucking delicious. Um,
these dipped and decorated berries.
Make both a thoughtful and have delicious,
enjoyable gift.
Sherry's berries has holiday gifts that
will bring joy to everyone on your list,
and they're just more than berries.
They got even more. They get snowman,
Brownie pops,
chocolate dip,
peppermint cookies and
cheesecake bites and lots more.
They will deliver your gifts fresh
to your door on the date you choose.
Here's the only way to
get today's one day deal.
Sherry's berries starting in 1999
in double the berries for $5 more.
Visit berries.com. B E,
r, R, I, e S. Dot Com.
Click on the microphone in the top
right hand corner. I'd type in Burr,
go to Barry's dot com.
Click on the microphone and type in Burr.
This deal ends today.
Oh Man,
I gotta pay my fucking taxes.
You sons of bitches. Um,
it'd be one thing if they actually fix
the potholes on this one, my fucking road.
You gotta be one thing. If they did that
almost sound like an old man right now.
MMM.
Anyways, I did a, uh,
mentioned,
oh fuck.
It's really is not a good feeling,
man. It was people. But, you
know,
I just,
I recommend not doing a podcast right
after you fucking eat one of these goddamn
things. Um, oh my God.
So anyways, like I mentioned, I did, uh,
I did fighter and the kid podcast today,
and when Brian Callen wasn't talking
about his amazing athletic physique,
I was talking, trying to talk
to a professional fighter. Uh,
Brendan Shab always said
his last name correctly. Um,
and I was just fascinated with the
ability to slip a punch and how they just
stare at the center of your chest and
look for some movement in your shoulders
and they're able to somehow slipped the
fucking punch. It was amazing to me.
We talked about cauliflower ears
and at what points you're not,
you can't drain them anymore because I
guess initially it's blood and then it
turns all fucking had. Um, I dunno,
that's probably more interesting than
anything that I fucking talked about.
But in everybody fights for a living man,
I wanted to talk more about that.
I hope I get to do the podcast again cause
if it's just a way to get Brian Count
is stop talking about himself,
there's somehow a way to do that.
Um, I had a lot of interesting
questions but you know,
Brian's somehow gets himself in between
you and the interesting thing that could
actually happen and he just has to
talk about is a geometric shape,
which I believe he described as an
upside down triangle being screwed into
something else. I don't
know. Manly an old TV tube.
I forgot what he described as lower
portion of his body, but you know,
it's just one description after
another about his amazing physique.
I'm fucking with the OCL. See
Brown county. Um, so listen
to that this week. And uh,
with that,
why don't I get into the fucking
questions before I literally fall asleep.
Alright. Uh, Terry Reed, everybody,
I don't know who that is.
I know Tara Reid, Rita's
Terry Reid. Hey there,
Billy Bilbo Baggins.
Just wondering if you ever
heard of Terry Reed. Uh,
he was offered by Jimmy page to be
the front man to his new yard birds.
Yeah.
Birds Band
and said that he had a couple of guys
that would be better for the job.
Robert Plant and John Bonham.
I love this story and I love Terry's
music. If you hadn't heard his stuff,
checkout seed of memory,
uh, to be treated right.
And Dean are my favorites.
I guess there's a documentary.
Super lungs is coming out soon anyways,
I've never heard you mentioned it before
and thought it'd be right up your alley.
Oh, well that's amazing. You know,
there's a bunch of those
kinds of fucking stories.
Like somebody sent me one recently,
I think I might've talked about it,
about a guy who filled in for Ringo
Starr for like two weeks at the height of
Beatle Mania.
Ringo had like tonsillitis or something.
And of course it was the early 60
[inaudible] so it was damn near fatal.
You know what I mean?
He had it yet.
I like fucking go to some witch
doctor Assam Shit to get cured.
So they had this other guy sit in and
he went from complete nobody to being
totally famous in every chicken,
the world that couldn't fuck
Lennon McCartney or fucking
Harrison was jumping on
his dick and then the whole fucking thing
ended two weeks later and no one knew
who he was. And he was just
like, what the fuck was that? Um,
and I guess, you know, he didn't
want to make a documentary out of it,
but I recently,
I was,
I was going through Twitter and they
showed a picture of them is great picture.
It's great for me looking at it to get
a sense of what it was like after he was
in the Beatles, probably crushing
for him. He was sitting in a,
I'm at an airport waiting for a flight.
And he was like the only guy there,
just sitting there by himself
with his Beatles haircut.
They made him get a Beatles haircut and
wear like a fucking Ringo style suit.
And uh, then he was just like, why,
what the, what the fuck happened?
Within two years he was broke and
out of the music business, um,
they just kind of lifted him up and
gave him all right there for it,
right back down. Uh, kind of incredible.
So I always find that amazing when
there was like people that were, uh,
you know, in bands. In fact,
I remember a long time ago I was
trying to develop this script,
but of course I've just,
I have too much add to try and get
these fucking ideas off the ground,
but had an idea for a,
for a movie and then they ended up kind
of doing the movie already with, uh,
just one of those guys from the
office. But my idea was, you know,
I used to watch those,
um,
those behind the musics and
there was always somebody,
oh fuck her cubs. The um, oh,
that burger is taking me
down. Um, there's, um,
there's always that person early on,
you know,
they're like in AC DC and they decide
to quit and go to school or they get
married and then the band goes on to
make it. And I always thought like,
what am it happened at that fucking
guy got to spend the rest of his life.
I don't give a shit what he does.
It can be a fucking brain surgeon.
People still like,
dude, you quit ac DC. Oh my God,
what a fucking loser.
Well, the rest of your life. So I
had this idea for movies of booze.
Basically it was about a guy that
quit a band and went on to make it.
And it was all about is I think I wrote
it for Adam Sandler cause it was the
late nineties when I was writing this
thing and it just, it was a fucking mess.
I was never able to land it.
And it basic,
what happened was he ends up meeting the
devil in a bar and he sells his soul to
go back in time to not quit the band.
So he stays in the band, he ends up
not meeting the love of his life.
And then he ends up discovering that the
reason why the band made it was because
he quit
and the right person got into the band.
So he lost his, the love of his life.
And the band didn't make it.
He fucked them all up and a,
and he was going to go to hell.
And, uh, interestingly enough,
that's where my script
went to hell because I,
the way I got out of it was then he
didn't give a shit. He was going to hell.
He fucking went out of his way to find
the fucking guy who should have been in
the band. So then the band makes it and
uh, because he did that selfless thing,
there was a loophole and selling your
soul, real Disney fucking ending.
And he gets beat,
doesn't have to sell his soul.
He gets back with his wife and then
they go to the concert in the end, oh,
this is how I should have done.
And he's like, you know what man,
I wouldn't trade being with you,
Sweden for all the fucking free
pussy in the world. The end.
Right. And they kind of
made a movie like that. Um,
or enough of it. Either way, I don't
give a fuck. Right. So anyways,
getting back to this Terry
Reid Guy, uh, was, I gonna say,
um, that sounds very interesting.
I'm actually, you know,
I'm going to fucking put this guy in
right now to look them up. Cherry re, man,
it sounds like a country guy.
Was that Jerry Reed?
I each of dad loaded
up, ain't fucking, um,
wife's.
You know,
we said that one night when he was just
sick of singing that song in front of
those fucking church going racing
racist fucking country music fans.
Ah, God. They love talking
about family. I'll tell you
right now, if I wasn't white,
I would not hang around with any white
people that talked about the family
values. The second white people
start talking about that shit.
You just know is she, you know what's
underneath that good family values,
you know,
founding fathers.
All right, let's go. Let's go. Let's not
get too political here, Bill. All right.
The wife's brother found
picture I posted online.
My wife's brother found a
picture. I posted it online. Okay.
Obviously it's not gonna
be good. First off, go fuck
yourself. All right. Thank you.
Very nice to see you too. Um, oh wait,
I forgot to read what this person
wrote it again. Just a binge drinking,
watching afters for family
right now. So far, I love it.
It mirrors the anger I have inside the
can't let out in a modern day society.
Thanks for all the free content and as
always, go fuck yourself. All right.
Just another guy watching
after his family.
Um, all right, this next guy,
my wife's brother found a picture I
posted online. All right. First off,
go fuck yourself. Hey, stop
B and me. Oh, by the way,
did anybody see will Ferrell on Jimmy
Fallon the tonight show this week doing
that?
Uh,
I got to give you a link to this even
though it already has 12 million fucking
views.
Um,
will Farrell is the new Santa Claus
and he's like, uh, like a Santa Brow.
Um, I, I can't do it justice. I can't
do, he's Kinda got a high pitch.
Hey Jamie. And he's got this
fucking blonde wig on with the soul.
I watched that.
It's like a fucking 10 minute video.
I've already watched it like four times.
I hate to say this.
I was actually watching it while driving
the other day. Just laughing. You know,
it's fucking traffic out here, you
know, but, uh, you gotta see it.
It's the fact that it's just a one off
character and that he came out and crush
that hard with it. The guy's an
absolute genius. And by the way,
he has a movie coming out called
Daddy's home star and Mark Walberg,
Boston's old Mark Walberg
and a yours truly has it.
Quick scene in there. I got a quick
seat, don't blanket, you'll miss me.
But that comes out on Christmas Day.
So if you already saw star wars,
which is hilarious, I heard it's fucking
awesome and now I want to go see it.
You have to meet trashing it.
Um,
versus he was fucking defended.
It was trying to say star
wars is not a nerd movie,
which is like me saying the New York
Yankees aren't a baseball team. Like it's,
it's not only a nerd movie, it's like a
nerd, nerd movie. You know what I mean?
That's like saying Goodfellas
is not a gangster movie.
It's more about interpersonal
relationships. Um, yeah,
it's the total fucking nerd movie,
but it's, it's fine. It's okay to be.
And he's defending it,
going like talking about what a great
jump shot he has and how he can throw a
football like an animal.
I love versa. He's always talking
trash man is always talking trash.
Um, so of course I gotta be a cunt
and I wrote them back on Facebook.
I'm going Paul,
not for nothing,
but when there's this full grown adults
dressing like the characters in the
movies that Gee, you got to expect
you're going to get a little bit of Shit.
Right. Cause he's trying to, he shouldn't
be negative KT when she has good Chai.
Me. Um, I think it's the
fact that the first four,
like three out of four
were either mediocre are
absolutely horrific and people
would rather line up and watch that shit.
And it's all truly amazing movies.
Truly amazing cinema out there.
All right.
A wise brother found picked that I posted
online. First off, got fucking on here.
I'll cut to the chase.
Be Nice if I did.
I've started this letter like three times.
I'm 22 and married Maddie
g's with two children.
One is biological data with that
word always reminds me of shacks.
Rep Cause is biological.
Didn't bother.
Remember that he was bobbing his head.
Of course he got him a convertible
cause he's like nine feet tall. Uh,
I got a little,
I got a little too shit faced the other
night and I shared skimpy pictures of my
wife's awesome ass.
Okay
on.
I can't tell where
you've got a little shit faced.
You've got a little too shit faced.
Long story short,
my wife's brother was also on there
and it came across these pictures.
My wife was passed out drunk and I drew
a monster eating a hot dog coming out of
her ass before taking the do.
This isn't real.
I don't want this to be real.
Okay.
So then you posted it on a porn site and
it turned out your brother in law was
on there.
Okay.
Oh your girlfriend's brother was on that.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going
on with brother-in-law?
Yeah,
this is,
that's actually a happy ending that the
circle of you three ended right there
and you guys just swirl around in
an eddy of that fucking nonsense.
Thank God that didn't go out and to
humanity like, like a virus. He goes,
my wife was pimp passed.
How he read this again.
My wife was passed out drunk and I drew
a monster eating a hot dog coming out of
her ass before taking the pictures.
Uh,
her brother is coming to town for the
holidays and I'm curious what you would do
in this situation. Why the fuck do
you know it was his sister's ass?
He was scrolling through a
look@thatass.com and then
all of a sudden he's just
like,
or do you have your own
name on this porno site?
What would you do it on Facebook?
Okay,
this is really weird.
You know what this is?
This might be one of the few law and
order episodes that were never made.
Don't Doh, Doh, Doh, Doh. And then
he shows up. You're like, hey man,
I was just a joke. And then he
fucking Daddy. Did he kill you?
Did the wife kill you? Who knows? Um,
her brother is coming to town
into town for the holidays.
I'm curious what you would do in this
situation. Uh, you mean? I don't know,
but aside from kill
myself, uh, I don't know.
Her brother already doesn't care for
me and I'm expecting an ass beating.
If he starts hitting me,
can I hit him back or just become
a punching bag for the evening?
Okay.
Uh, how old are you? You got keys? 22.
Wait, you sir,
you've made a series of bad decisions
in life and it's ended with this and I
think it's,
it's great that the year is ending,
that you're in this situation and I would
try to do something to get out of it.
Eh,
the first thing I'd do,
I'd stopped drawing pictures on my wife's
ass and putting them on the Internet.
Secondly, I would take some
self defense classes and, uh,
put my wife's brother and his place,
but he's going to be right on this one.
Okay.
The only way he knows it's your wife's
ass as if somehow your name is connected
to that account.
So I'm guessing you went on Facebook
for friends and family and your fucking
wife's ass with the hot dog coming
out of it. That's really weird.
Probably those was like fucking Shit,
didn't it?
You were to a fucking turd
coming out of our ass. Um,
yeah. For brother, if anybody starts
hitting, you can always hit back.
I just try to tie him up.
Just get him in a bear hug and just
get your mouth in his ear going,
I'm sorry dude. I'm sorry. I'm Joe.
I'm sorry. Just keep doing that.
Maybe that'll work. I have no idea.
That's a hell of a predicament. Anyways,
he goes,
thank you for absence from family.
It's the only show that is funnier
than South Park Day. Easy, easy. No,
it isn't a South Park for king. I love
the podcast and of course the advice.
Go Fuck yourself as much as I f I fucked
myself. Well, good luck with that one.
Um,
and final.
Okay.
Uh,
Dear William Claus,
I'm buying a couple of
friends slash relatives,
some vinyl this year for Christmas.
Needs some help.
I want to get a couple of
classic rock and jazz albums.
So you are near or the dude
who does your podcasts.
Okay.
Or even your mailman have any suggestions?
Yeah,
well I think bill burr live at
Andrew's house is a hell of a,
that's a hell of a record
to own personally speaking.
I think it's phenomenal
if I do say so myself. Um,
uh, what, what, what, what kind of a
what kind of, what kind of judge
you want to listen to? I mean,
you could go with the classics if
you just didn't come out. You know,
you have the ones that
everybody gets to try it.
Even though people try to pretend like
they're into jazz, like me know, you know,
like, uh, God, what are those
miles Davis one Bertha. Cool.
The one with my funny Valentine
on it might be that one. Yeah.
Well, well, well,
well,
right
John Coltrane, a love supreme.
That's deaths. Fuck him up that day.
Sounds like a baby playing the
fucking saxophone to me, if,
if it actually knew what it was doing,
but didn't understand how
to make sentences yet. Um,
I always like miles Davis in a silent way.
A classic rock albums.
Quantum man Zeplin too.
Uh, ACDC back in black. I
Dunno. I Dunno what to tell you.
I Dunno. I got a giant Burger sitting in
me and it's slowly, you notice you don't,
I feel like,
I feel like this must be what it's like
after you get bit by a poisonous snake.
After the pain is gone
and the horror is gone,
the serpent has left the area and you
just given into the fact like, hey man,
I'm just going to ride this up.
I'm going to start hallucinating and I
might wake up dead and some of the place
or I might just die right here right now.
Um,
saw [inaudible] self,
I can't even talk about it.
Like I saw something so
fucked up the other day.
I was watching those animal clips,
eight animals that don't have the decency
to kill another animal before they
start eating it. You know,
reptiles are big on that.
So reptile, one time, you
know, it was giant bowls at
fucking routinely kill lions.
Komodo dragon fucking bid in it leg.
And it's got such bacteria and its teeth
in his mouth that it knows it's going
to get into the bowls fucking
blood system and it's going
to collapse.
But it takes like three days.
So there's a lizard just keeps following
this thing around and waiting for it to
collapse, not die, collapsed.
And then it comes up and just starts
eating its guts as the fucking cows.
It's just horrific. I don't know why
I'm bringing that up. You know what?
I brought that up. Let's see if I can make
you laugh after that. Fucking immature.
All right. TV show, TV
show recommendations.
Um, number one, a Billy Bob read.
Fuck a Billy Bob read.
Fuck. How's it going?
And that's actually a good
one and I fucked it up.
I have a show you need to watch. It's
called Ray Donovan, starring, uh,
Liev Schreiber. It's about a Boston
family that moves to La and the,
why are you acting like this
isn't a massive fucking, uh,
a massive hit plays a fixer
for celebrities and high
profile people in the city.
It's fucking amazing.
I know you'd like it.
It's got Busan and bang and
tits and death. The four
components of his sick show.
Take a watch. You won't be disappointed.
Thanks for all the podcasts.
Always gets me through the day.
Go Fuck Yourself. I'm actually,
I want to start watching that show
because I'm a good friend of mine,
Mike by,
um,
who directed black or white who's become
one of my really good friends and uh,
he's actually signed on to start
writing on that show and uh,
I was talking to him the other day.
He says he wakes up early,
excited to go to work.
He's loving working on the show and he
was telling me how sick some of the shows
are that they're making right now.
So I'm definitely,
I'm going to try to get
caught up on that one.
So thank you for the recommendation. Do
you have any more? I'll look at that.
Recommendation number two.
All right.
Uh,
dear Billy sloops,
the 2009 BBC Sherlock Holmes t v show,
starring Benedict Cumberbatch is awesome.
The acting is great.
Great. It's shot well. There are only
four seasons, four episodes per season.
Very well done. It's on Netflix and
there were a couple of seasons, you know,
I'm going to give that a shot.
Sherlock Holmes was always really
dry cause he's so fucking cerebral.
I liked those cops that, you know, they
smack people around, you know what I mean?
And then drink and shit. They solve shit
the way, you know, the way people want.
Smart.
Do you know,
they get themselves liquored
up and they use violence.
I like watching that shit, so
I'll, I'll sit with that. You know,
I always feel like Sherlock Holmes
is like Europe's doctor who,
but if it's only four episodes per
season, hey, I think I could do that.
But Oh, this Burger Burger's taking me
down. I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
Guys, this might be my last
Monday morning podcast.
I want to thank all you guys for
listening over the last decade. Hey,
bill speeches.
Slowly gonna become slurred.
Vision is beginning to double
o be able to go on what the others.
This is how it ends. All right. Hey Bill.
Not sure if you've seen the nick yet,
but it's a great show.
Clive Owen is great.
He's a heroin slash coke addict doctor
who does experimental surgeries in 1901
AH, Jesus Christ. I'm on board
every time my wife and I watch it,
we always say Jesus Christ.
Oh,
oh Jesus Christ. The way you do because
of the crazy shit that goes down.
Give it a watch and allow yourself to say
the same thing. Thanks for the laughs.
All right,
I'll try that number four dear bell,
have you heard of this new show? F is for
family. Why? No, I have not. Wink, wink.
Let me read. Let me read the description.
It's voiced by the redheaded,
the redhead from,
I love the 80 strikes back.
Bruce Stern's daughter does a voice too.
It's an accurate portrayal of life from
the 70s filled with all types of humor.
The language is a bit salty,
so make sure not to watch it on Sundays.
I heard they signed for four
and a half more seasons,
so don't expect to see the red head
on VH one anytime soon. Love you man.
Thanks for the laughs. Ah, wasn't that
sweet? That was a nice little gift there,
wasn't it? All right. Winding down here.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I told myself the other day I was going
to wrap the Christmas gifts and just
fucking just put this whole
Christmas thing to bed, you know,
cause the next few nights I'm going
to a bunch of Christmas parties
and uh, you know what I mean? Oh God.
Why did I do that Burger today? And then
I go, he's Christmas parties. You know,
I,
you know what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna fucking the second I'm done with
this shit. I'm, I upload this podcast,
I'm shoving my giant head under some water
and I'm waking the fuck up and
I'm going to go to the gym.
I'm going to go to the gym every day.
Gotcha.
Just become pop me life fed.
If you don't what I be faith or you go
to the gym every day, you can't. Um,
all right, dilemma. Here is
a dilemma for you, dear bill,
their billion, uh, my girlfriend
said no gifts for Christmas.
She looked me dead in the eye and said,
please no gifts
this year. Wow, that's great.
To give you the backstory,
we got engaged a month ago and they're
also going to London in February.
She's not the type of girl to bullshit
about this or test me like some psycho.
She really meant it. Oh, oh
this, this is a tough one.
I was thinking about making her a card
or something laying slash awesome like
that.
What can I do that doesn't count as a
gift but still says I needed to give you
something.
Um,
all your listeners are probably
going to suggest giving her the Dick
and there you go. I think that's a
great idea. This is what should do.
You go out and you buy a little thread
that you can tie into a bow, your wrapper,
you tied around your fucking Dick and
then you on some Christmas music go,
we comes Santa Claus,
here comes Santa Claus right
down Santa Claus Lane and he is,
you just run in like high
kicking with your junk.
Just flapping in the wind with,
with the ball around it. Right.
If you do that,
I bet you'll never have to buy or anything
else for Christmas again cause she'll
probably leave you and then you go,
all your problems will be solved.
Okay.
I Dunno if, do you think she
really means it? You know,
don't buy me anything for Christmas.
Oh God.
Do they ever say what they mean? It's
always a game. It's always a test.
They're, they're higher thinkers.
They're a higher level big,
they speak in metaphors wrapped up in an
enigma with a rental and something else
from fucking JFK strikes
back with the empire,
whatever it is.
Um,
okay.
Which, what could you get her? Why
don't you just make a breakfast?
We were in a Santa Hat.
Something simple like that.
Okay.
You know why? You know why I don't
buy this? Because it's never enough.
Even if you go onto,
yeah,
get him some shit. It's not going to
be an, and there's always something we,
something needs to be worked on.
Something needs to happen.
What are we doing here? Um, oh fuck.
That was me sitting up. I just
made that noise. You know,
somebody sent me a fucking video of this
drummer I never heard of and I'm going
to fucking send you will.
His name is Charles something or other.
He's a jazz drummer and he is an absolute
fucking monster and he's really fun to
watch for any drummers who listen to this.
I don't think drummers listened to this
for anybody happens to be a drummer,
but you fucking listen to this. Uh, let
me see if I can get the fucking name here.
What is the name of this motherfucker?
What is the name of this mother fucker?
It guy's name is Charlie Antolini.
Okay.
Charlie Antolini.
Um,
okay.
I actually got this, uh,
I got it this morning.
Somebody sent it to me. Might or might
not have been. I want to drop a name here,
but he may or not may not be the
drummer from truths and salvage company.
He sent it to me and he was like,
check this fucking guy out and
he's a monster. So I'm going to,
I'm going to have this clip up on the
podcast to get you a little drummer,
shit going on. But uh, I'm going
to dunk my fucking giant head
underneath the fucking the water right
now that this is, this is it guys. I
can't, I'm trying to get to an hour.
I get another fucking three minutes.
I mean,
technically I work for myself
so I can take off early. Right?
It's the fucking holidays. I've been
sticking with that Mike Johnston, um,
bass drum workout workout.
And by sticking with it,
I mean I've done it two days in a row.
He recommends at least five days a
week for three months for 15 minutes.
You do is based drum fucking workout.
And then you two will
have a faster bass drum.
What did anyone want to
say? Doing the workout too.
So I really want to stick with it.
Um,
and I feel like if I don't go today,
I'm going to fuck the whole thing
up. I got to do it. I have to do it.
And that's what I'm going to go to.
As always,
if you would like to support this podcast
and really not doing anything while
you're doing your Christmas shopping
this year, if you go to amazon.com, uh,
a way to donate to this podcast,
it doesn't cost you a dab
is too hard. I'm fading.
I'm fame is to, um,
go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com and you
click on the merchant page,
not the march pays the podcast page.
We have an Amazon link.
You Click on that fucking thing.
It takes you to Amazon.
I get credit for driving traffic to
amazon.com. You go out, you buy something.
They kicked me a little. Thank you.
Thank you. And uh, then it's all good.
It's all good. And then, uh,
you know, I always, you know,
every once in a while I
take some of that money.
I throw in something
like Saint Jude Hospital
and the next thing you know, every fucking
charity in the world that goes all,
we got a live one, we got a live,
one of the next thing you know,
I get a bunch of fucking junk mail and
I have to say the whole fucking planet
and I'm sitting, they go,
well why did I do that?
I just helped out some kid with
cancer and, and then, then, then,
then they fucking chop down 50
trees selling me more shittier.
So that is going to get cured.
He's not going to have a fucking
treated hang his swing on,
you know what I mean? Did you
just, it just doesn't work.
It doesn't work. You know,
I had a fucked up conversation with
somebody today about, you know,
I was watching one of those space
and it was fucking scientists guys.
And we're talking about how there's
like 30,000 earths out there in space.
You don't want it habitable places
like this with water and all that shit,
but you know, they just don't have an
Epcot center. So you know it's not earth,
right. And everybody always thinks, well,
maybe there's a bunch of human beings run
around there. And I was thinking, well,
maybe there's some dinosaurs up there.
Maybe the asteroid never heard it,
you know, and have a hit. And
maybe human beings, you know,
crawled out of the fucking,
out of the trees, a mud or
whatever the fuck they did.
And uh, the Getty, you know,
but it turns source rhexis
right then. Then they're up there fucking
eat and all the fucking trees and shit.
You ever think stuff like that?
Well, you know something. I do. Fuck.
20 more seconds. 19 seconds.
18 more seconds. All right.
Have yourself a merry little Christmas.
Even if you're not Christian.
I hope you had a happy
Hanukkah or Kwanzaa.
And if you're a Muslim, I don't
know what it is. You celebrate.
All right then that's it. Ah,
I'm in an hour. There you go.
All Billy food bag here. I'm
done. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.
All right.
See you.